hola raúl amaneció con mucha polémica
recordemos son dos millones setecientos
mil personas las que están concernidas
por esta medida y no hay plazo que se
cumpla el presidente manuel macro no la
había anunciado en julio hay incluso una
ley está inscrita en una ley sanitaria y
hoy comienza ese plazo las personas
tienen que tener hoy 15 de septiembre al
menos una vacuna y tener la segunda
dosis antes del 15 de octubre si no
serán suspendidos de su trabajo y quien
dice no trabajo no salario tampoco de
raúl pero también puede haber medidas
disciplinarias por parte del lugar donde
la persona trabaje decías bien tú no
solo son los médicos son todo el
personal sanitario pero también personas
que trabajan de manera independiente y
tienen contacto con personas enfermas o
vulnerables por ejemplo la señora que te
vende medicamentos en la farmacia un
chofer de ambulancia los mismos bomberos
que aquí en francia son los encargados
de los primeros auxilios en todo caso
las cifras que entrega el gobierno y el
ministerio de salud dicen que al menos
los profesionales liberales están
vacunados con las dos dosis en un 94%
raúl y las personas que trabajan en los
hogares de ancianos es en un
88% mucho cuidado deben también tener
los médicos liberales los que tienen su
consultorio porque ellos van a ser
controlados a partir de hoy también si
por ejemplo trabajan sin tener las dos
vacunas tienen una multa de 135 euros si
reinciden tres veces tres mil
750 euros e incluso podrían raúl tener
una pena de cárcel además por ejemplo de
una sanción de parte del colegio de
médicos
erika pues una controvertida ley muchas
protestas estaban muy movido hoy sobre
todo en la capital parís gracias por el
reporte y por la información